hello, how is hector mejía in health with
his brief informative today is thursday
april 29 today the governor of snowfall and
excess to cris and tara the
employee vaccination site within the
median owes this to the fact that he will talk about
efforts to minimize the spread
of the virus
this visit happens as more
restrictions are eliminated as
of Saturday the capacity will allow the
places will be 80% the
social distancing will be more reduced and the
restaurants will be able to serve more
people per table the first of June is
the goal to reopen  completely
the nevada employment department
known as didier plans to update
their system tonight the
online pages of twitter and kinect will not be
working from 7 to 9 pm during this
period of time
new applicants will not be able to fill out forms to
claim benefits this maintenance
it will not impact those who are already
registered
the pasquini hotel organizes a
job fair today at 10 in the morning  at one in
the afternoon they will be interviews in person
you could even get the job
today remember that you can fill out the
application prior to the event also on the
site visited kim l from dotcom
for more information on
job opportunities you can visit our page
and illusion dotcom diagonal at  Spanish
and now we turn to the weather forecast
we will have temperatures reaching 90
degrees for today even more heat is expected
for this weekend reaching almost
100 degrees for Saturday and Sunday
have nice newspapers from héctor mejía and
this was his brief informative of  home
in spanish